Now I know at some point, we will have a memorial for Kobe.
But I look at this as a celebration  tonight.
This is a celebration of the 20 years of the blood, the sweat, the tears,...
...the broken down body that getting up, sitting down to everyday in the countless hours.
The determination to be as great as he could be.
Tonight, we celebrate the kid that came here at 18 years of age.
Retired at 38 and became probably the best daddy that we've seeing over the last three years, man.
Tonight is a celebration.
Before we get to play,...
Love you all, man.
Kobe is a brother to me and from the time I was in highschool,...
...to watch him from afar.
To get in this league at 18, watching him up close.
All the battles we had throughout my career.
The one thing that we always share is the determination to just want to win.
I just want to be great.
And the fact that I'm here now means so much to me.
I want to continue along with my teammates to continue his legacy not only for this year...
...but as long as we could play the game of basketball that we love...
...because that's what Kobe Bryant will want.
So in the words of Kobe Bryant, "Mamba out".
But it the words of us, "Not forgotten".
Live on brother.